hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game app from this year's video
world team championship it's a game
between Han smoke and Neiman and Shakir
mamiyarov It's a Wonderful attacking
game but it will be hard at times to
even imagine who who is the actual
attacker uh as you'll see what I mean by
this so Hans has the white pieces and
this is round two in round one uh Hans
drew his game against sarados
lavoitashek and um won his game against
uh another Rebecca
Uzbekistan so like I said this is their
second game and Hans opens with uh Pawn
to E4 we're gonna have some 10 moves of
theory not too much as sometimes we have
even 20 moves of known Theory so E5
Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and Bishop the
B5 Hans goes for the real Lopez and if
you are wondering uh why Hans is playing
board one for the United States as the
United States has quite a lot of very
very strong Grand Masters none of them
are playing so that's why my hands is
playing board one even though he is
almost 2700 rated and the mamidaro of
course is the top rated player from
Azerbaijan so that's why he's playing
board one uh so uh Bishop to B5 Dory
Lopez A6 morphe's defense Bishop to A4
and Knight to F6 we have castles and not
Knight captures on e4 so this is all
very standard stuff we've seen this many
times D4 B5 attacking the bishop Bishop
to B3 and now Pawn to D5 with d captures
on E5 and Bishop to E6
and defending the D5 Pawn Knight beat
the D2 and now Knights the C5 attacking
the bishop on B3 and here there are some
over 1400 games where C3 was played but
Hans plays Queen to E2 and okay it's not
a new move it has been played like a
dozen times uh but only in lower level
uh uh tournaments and games so when I
say lower level I mean like the the
highest rated player that played Queen
to E2 with some 2400 maybe 2450 and for
these gentlemen that's lower rated uh
and uh all of the games were Queen T2
was played were continued with a bishop
D7 interestingly Bishop to A7 is the
strongest move recommended by the engine
uh but Mama there are plays Pawn to G6
and it is now as of move 10 that we have
a completely new game so Hans definitely
uh took a mediev by surprise here uh we
have C3 now and Bishop to G7 not
interested in capturing and that uh the
the bishop B3 if you capture and Knight
captures the knight uh will have access
to C5 indefinitely as you are probably
developing your Bishop to G7 and once
this Knight lens on C5 uh it's never
going away so instead after C3 Bishop to
G7 now comes Knight to D4 attacks the
Knight on C6 so
trades but not on D4 he goes for the
pawn on E5 and Hans is saying you should
grab this pawn and okay mamajarov does
Knight captures on E5 Ponte F4 Knight E
to D3 now an excellent Square for the
Knight and pawn to F5 so this is uh all
well within hans's preparation I believe
now attacking the bishop here and you
have two choices here either we play G
captures
on F5 of course the bishop cannot move
the bishop he spin the king is an E8 or
you go Knight captures and C1 those are
your only two options and they are quite
similar so a Hans played Knight captures
on C1 uh Rook a captures on C1 and now G
captures an F5 we have Knight captures
on F5 and now Bishop to F6 you could
also consider maybe Castle in here
decides to go Bishop to F6 and now comes
Bishop to C2 also very interesting is
Knight to D4 now this is really asking
black a lot of very unpleasant questions
uh well one for one being do capture on
D4 but once you do this once you give up
the dark Square Bishop look at the C
characters on D4 and now where is the
Knight going
if you don't want to allow something
like Queen to E5 that will put immense
pressure you will have to go captures
captures and then Knight gets the C5
Square for example Queen to D6 Knight
will end on C5 and you are never getting
rid of this Knight this is a can just
resign here so this is uh what what
could happen however after night the D4
you don't have the capture you could
also just play some like Bishop to G7
then white continues Bishop C2 and the
game uh just uh well continues uh so
after Bishop to F6 Bishop to C2 was
played by Hans now we have Knight the D7
this is very nice as it um uh well uh
prepares Queen E7 queen to queen to C5
you know that the Knight will not remain
on F5 and here Knight the D4 by a Hans
here the absolute top move recommended
by the engine is King the H1 and the
king would be very nicely placed on H1
but okay Knights the D4 by Hans uh Queen
to E7 and now Rook C the E1 uh putting
both queen and the rook and the E file
which is very nice as you can see but
now mamidarov can uh just trade down and
and go into uh well uh in in equal game
Bishop captures on the 4C captures and
just Queen side castles and now you
might think but yes but now Hans will
get the C5 Square for his knight uh
interestingly it's not all that potent
now so here at night the B3 Queen to D6
and not not a knight to C5 First Pawn to
A4 Hans knows that mommy draw will now
use the G file uh to attack his King so
he wants to make his attack and the
queen side happen uh just a little bit
sooner so he gives up a pawn temporarily
for that uh B captures on A4 Knight to
A5 now and now interestingly nice it
doesn't even come to see five nights to
A5 and now Queen to B6 putting pressure
on the knight uh Queen to D2 defending
and now Rook D to G8 preparing now to
attack the white king Bishop captures an
A4 and now a beautiful move by Mommy
there are pretty much the only one that
doesn't
um give Hans the upper hand and that is
Rook to G4 with Tempo not only uh are
you preparing to double up on the G file
but you are also threatening need to
pick up the D4 Pawn so here at Knight
the C6 this is how Hans defends it the
Knight now defends the D4 Pawn Knight to
B8 uh trying to eliminate this Knight as
it's a very strong piece uh H3 attacking
the rook and here uh Shakira just says
I'm not interested in uh anything you're
doing here on the king side you can have
that Rook I'm just gonna play Knight
captures and C6 and here yeah Mama jar
of Gibbs gives up the exchange uh for DD
for pawn and for some very interesting
counter play
uh so H characters on G4 Knight captures
on D4 now threatening some very nasty
discoveries if the knight ever moves
Queen to E3 and now Rook the G8 getting
the other Rook into the game as well
Bishop to D1 defending the G4 Pawn but
um it doesn't really matter Bishop
captures on G4 Rook to F2 The Rook will
also be needed regarding the G2 Pawn
Plus you want to have something extra in
between that black queen on B6 and King
and G1 so Bishop captures on D1 Rook
captures and now for the second time in
the game Rook to G for the absolute
strongest for mamidarov uh seems like
you're just Defending Your Knight here
but the real thing is that you are
leaving hunts without a move really uh
you know let's say you try something
like like Rook F to D2 just Knight to F3
with check look at this how how do you
stop this uh now if you capture the
Knight you just lose the queen and if
you play uh King to F2 the guard the
queen then you give up The Rook here and
okay you can trade but even if Queen
captures on V6 there's the in-between
Knight the E4 check and you just lose
everything King moves now C capture some
B6 you're just up a full Knight
so instead after Rook to G4 Rook the D3
was played now uh you you are no longer
allowing such things and uh Here Comes
Rook to E4 attacking hans's Queen and uh
Queen to G5 is the way to go but Hans
plays Queen to H3 with check and now it
will be a bit difficult to defend this
position with white king the B7 we have
rooked the E3 with Queen to D7 hunts is
still in the game but he plays Rook to
E3 he wants to trade off the Rooks and
now there is only one move that wins the
game for Shakira so feel free to pause
the video and try to find this
incredible idea while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on sporting this
uh idea as it's not the first thing that
comes to mind and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Pawn
to F5 and now with this pawn move uh on
uh played uh you are ensuring that if
Rook ever captures an E4 you are playing
F characters on e4 and you will have two
connected pass pawns the problem is if
you play something like A5 let's say you
could also play this this is even the
the second uh top move recommended by
the engine now white will happily
capture an E4 you will have that capture
with the d-pawn and now okay white will
unpin so now the Rook can move and after
F5 yes you are getting some Pawn action
here but Queen to E3 Queen to C5 you're
gonna play Rook to D2 you're gonna go
after the Knight and after some like
Queen C1 check King H2 and C5 you will
play Queen to H6 and now you will win
the H7 Pawn with check and you are you
are still very much in the game so
that's one way to do it however after F5
it's just not clear how to how to play
this one thing you you might consider is
just capturing that pawn on H7 but if
you do this now there are well the rook
and E3 is hanging so there's that so
instead after this uh F5 move we have
King the H1 first unpinning from this
diagonal finally and now Knight to B5
this is a beautiful move by mamajarov As
It prepares Knight to D6 which will be
crucial later on in the defense of the
C8 Square as you'll see uh plus it opens
up the Queen's diagonal so the Rooks are
now attacked you are threatening to just
pick up the Rook here Rook capture Sunny
for you could also play Rook fde too but
it's not much better Rook captures and
E4 F characters now Rook the f8
threatening Queen to see it check but
not Knight to D6 stopping that Queen to
ca to check idea Queen captures an H7
and now Queen captures on B2 so similar
like in the game Magnus played that
we've shown in the previous round uh
mamajarov is down the exchange but he's
up three pawns which is not as great and
as in that game but it's it's I mean
it's a lot so Queen to G8 trying to get
that Rook to G8 checking to win the
black queen and now Queen A1 check King
to H2 Queen to E5 check and queen to G3
offering a queen trade
uh which my major of declines if you
don't want to play this you could also
play King to G1 but then some like Queen
to D for checking H2 and E3 and this
Pawn is very close to promotion even if
you give one check doesn't really matter
the Knight here does an excellent the
job of preventing the White Queen from
delivering checks and you will just uh
Advance your Pawn to Victory so instead
after Queen E5 Queen to G3 he blocks
check but not mommy drop says we are not
trading Queens just yet Queen H5 check
King to G1 Queen to D1 check King H2 and
now Queen to H5 checklist it seems like
he is trying to get a repetition but not
really King to G1 and now D4 he's just
trolling Hans as it would seem uh Rook
to F1 and now Queen the C5 threatening
some nasty discoveries here Rook the B1
check King to A7 and now Queen to F2
stopping D3 because just Queen captures
and uh C5 so Knights the B5 closing of
the B file and adding a Defender to the
D4 on Rook to A1 and now we have Knight
to C3 G4 there is nothing left for hunts
in this game other than to try and push
that g Pawn to Victory E3 attacks the
queen queen to F6 and now you have to
again be very careful you don't want to
mess up and blunder the A6 Pawn so Queen
C4 shark defends this and now Queen to
E5 we have Pawn to E2 uh and then now
Pawn to G5 we have D3 uh Queen to E3
with check King to B7 and now Queen to
F3 with check Knight the E for blocking
and Rook to B1 with check King the C6
and now Queen to f8 uh and there are
many ways to win this of course the
position is completely winning for black
but uh my major chooses the simplest one
and that of course is Queen to C5 with
check he forces the queen trade and he
was in this position and move 57 that
Hans Neiman resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here I forgot
to mention in the previous video I think
uh the game between Magnus and Duda
ended in 64 moves and there is nothing I
like more than for a chess game to end
in 64 moves that's always very nice okay
there are some things I like more but I
I really enjoy that uh so yeah Queen C5
uh Hans resigns and a very nice win for
yarov uh taking down uh the first board
for the United States and uh gaining a
very very important Point uh so now you
resign because after the queen trade
which is uh well a must captures
captures Rook the C1 check can be played
but after King D4 there is no stopping
the pawns if King rookie one just D2 and
if captures D1 uh queening uh there
there is no way to play this it's uh
completely winning for mamidarov uh so
yeah uh that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed that first game that we are
showing from the video world team
championship 2022 hope you enjoyed it
and if you have any of your own
favorites do use hashtag suggestion in
the comments I will look over it and try
to show some uh interesting games from
this uh this tournament uh so once again
hope you enjoyed it uh I would like to
thank Francis Sarah Carmen polyfronio
and Sinister Paul and Roshan reptiles
YouTube before and AI mind for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event and whatever else
happens in the Chess World thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day